une boulangerie entièrement détruite
quatre logements réduisent en cendres
cet après-midi les braises était encore
chaude une scène désastreuses pour les
occupants heureusement sain et sauf ce
que vous voyez là c'est ma maison qui a
brûlé
donc ça n'arrive pas qu'aux autres c'est
une catastrophe ça s'apprend on comprend
pas comme le montrent ces images
tournées la nuit dernière
les flammes se sont propagées rapidement
dans ce pâté de maison située dans le
bourg d'art kg en pierre qui réside tout
près a été réveillé par la violence de
l'incendié
il a assisté à toute la scène quand j'ai
vu cette flamme qui partait du bain il y
avait un espèce de somiedo et il ya la
flamme monter jusqu'en haut des maisons
quoi et moi j'ai une espèce d'appentis à
côté là ça ces prix là dedans ça tout
emmené en très très peu de temps
aujourd'hui dix habitants se retrouvent
désormais privés de logements pour la
mairie il faut rapidement trouver des
solutions nous avons peu de
disponibilité dans le village
en ce qui concerne des logements
communaux mais on va peut-être trouvé
chez les privés
et puis on peut aussi avoir des
solutions transitoires en attendant
voilà de faire mieux
concernant les circonstances précises de
l'incendié l' enquête a été confiée à la
brigade de gendarmerie de cosne sur
loire origine accidentelle ou criminelle
pour l'heure aucune hypothèse n'est
privilégiée